ただいまンコ
んあぁあぁあ〜、久しぶりに帰って来れたよー
こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
ま、Twitterとかで知ってる方は知っていると思うんですけども
私、はじめしゃちょー
一週間ほど
え〜っと〜・・・、
２泊６日の旅です
ま、どこで何してたかっていうのは
まぁまぁまぁまぁ、お楽しみに！
またどこかでお知らせします
(ﾄﾞﾝｯ!)
マジねーあのねー
２泊６日の旅ねー
すっっっっっっっっっっっっっっっっっっっっっっっ
(顔w)
ごくキツかったです！
だって2泊 3日(6日) だよ！？
６日間もあったのに俺は
２泊しか、ホテルに泊まることが、無かった！
後はもう、飛行機でなんかしてるか、移動してるかの何かで
もうホントねぇ、もう精神心身共にもう
ボカン(?) でしたからね、ホントに
びっくりしたんですけども、まぁその分
いい、旅に、なったと、思っております
楽しかった楽しかった！
ハッハッハッハッハッ
なわけねぇだろぉぉぉおおおおおお！！！！！
なわけねぇだろぉ！！
僕ちょっと旅をすると、必ずトラブルが起きるっていう
あるんですよそういうのが
えっと、かつて！
５、６年前に
財布を無くしました
見つかったけど、現金がすべて抜き取られていました
卒業旅行、イタリアの旅、
イタリアの詐欺師にあって
３万円くらいぶん盗られました
そして今回！
２泊６日のうちの１泊のとき
ホテルにこう、泊まったんですよ
で！
ふぅ〜と思って、
ホテルでこうやってスーツケースをドンって置いて
ふぅ、スーツケース置いてさて出かけますか
って言ったときに
なんかその治安がいいとも言えない場所だったんで、
ホテルに荷物置くのもちょっと怖かったんで、
スーツケースにも鍵をかけようかなと思って
ここ鍵かけれるんすよ、このスーツケース
３桁こうやって、カチャカチャカチャってやって鍵かけれるとこなんですよ
で、こうやっていつも通り僕の誕生日の２１４・・・
これ言っていいのかな？
ダメだな
なんかこう僕のなんか特殊な３つの数字（２１４）をこうやって打って
鍵掛けれました！つってこうやって、
持ち手のとこをこうやってカチャンカチャンってやって
よしっ！
と思って、もう１回こうやって、２１・・・あ・・・
３つの僕の数字（２１４）パンポンポンってやったら、
終わった！
イタッ！
待って！
ｺﾝ！
俺の旅の終わりでした。
なので僕もうその旅の途中から、
一切スーツケースの中身を使うことができませんでした
俺スーツケース持ち歩いてるだけでもうホントねぇ
もう取り出せるものがこれぐらいしかなくて
ホントもう詰んでだんすよ
ｶﾁｬｶﾁｬｶﾁｬ
もうホント開かないんすよ！
開かないんすよ！！
え、多分ね、２１４でかけたと思うんすけど開かなくて
たぶんずれてんのかな、３１４とか...
違う、１１４も違う
なんかまちがえて…どっかでまちがえてロックしちゃったのかなって説はぜったいあるんだと思ったんですけど…
だって開かないんだもん…　２２５…いやまじで開かないんすよね
いやいやおかしいでしょお…
なんかもう、旅行中もいろいろ試したんですけど一向に開く予定がなくて…
これUUUMの確か登録者何人記念の時にいただいたものでもう３、４年くらいすごい大切に使っている物なんですけど…
開かないな
助けて（切実）
ダイヤル押せば開くみたいな…
いや、むりだなあ！開かないよこれ！！終わった！
って言うのを俺旅の先で何回もやったんですよ！
けど帰って来ても開かないって俺この中身どうしたらいいって話なんですよ！！！
あああぁああぁあぁあぁあぁあぁあぁあぁぁぁぁツラァ…
でもね？
幸いなことに僕このスーツケースもう結構壊れてまして
あの、ロックかかってもここちょっと穴開いてるんすよね、もう
うまくいけばここから服だけこうやってとりだせる可能性があるんすよね
よっしゃ、せーたー！　セーターゲット！
良かった逆にもう
スーツケースが壊れてて良かったところではありますね
これ全部取り出せるんじゃね？
(はじめん頑張りタイム)
⚠︎謎の変顔にご注意ください⚠︎
ここまでのようだ
000から999までの全部試すと解除できる可能性があるんですけど時間がもったいない！！
やだあ！
やだしまてないよ　だってあけてくれるひとのとこにいったりして　あけなきゃいけないっていうことでしょ〜
待てません
ぼくまてな〜い！
というわけで！
僕よく東京に行くことが多くて
３年間くらい 本当にずっと愛用させていただきました このスーツケース
もう服がはみ出るくらい壊れちゃってるんで、
まあそういうことでしょう
今まで本当にありがとう・・・
うぅうぅうぅうぅうぅ・・・
いや もう壊すしかないんですよ。
壊すしかない。
だってこの中すごい大切なもの入ってるんですよ
これを機に
新しいスーツケースを買おうと思います
またね、これ壊れてなかったら話は別だと思うんですけども、
結構これ　穴空いてるのが
物落ちちゃったりしてたので
３年間よく持った
壊します
。・゜・(ノД`)・゜・。
ちゃんと壊せる方法があったら最高なんですけども、
これもう、力づくでやるしかないな
ああ、びっくりした
こう、力でバキバキっつって開けば一発なんですけど
こうやって中で通して
あ　取れた！
良い子は絶対に真似しないでね！
(よいこはぜったいにまねしないでね！)
ここで絶対に動画を止めないで！
↑=1オクターブ上の音
ﾗｰ
ﾗ ﾗ# ｼ ﾄﾞ↑ｰ  ﾗｰ
ﾄﾞ↑ ﾗ# ﾗ ﾗ#ｰ
ﾗ# ｼ ﾄﾞ↑ ﾚ↑ｰ ﾗ#ｰ
ﾚ↑ ﾄﾞ↑ ﾗ# ﾄﾞ↑ｰ ﾌｧ↑ｰ ﾐ↑ ﾚ↑
ﾗ# ﾗ ﾗ# ﾐｰ ｿｰ ﾌｧｰ
ﾌｧﾌｧﾌｧﾌｧ
ﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞ
取れた取れた！
え、ちょろちょろちょろ
え、待ってこんなに簡単に取れていいものなのか?
気合いでいけるもんだな思ったより
ていうことはこっちもひょっとしたらもう
気合いでいけるんじゃねえか説がある
（凸してる変顔）
あ゛っ
とれた！
え まって
もろっ
やったあ！
え 待ってやった！
なんか普通に開けました！
マジで開かねえなと思ったんですけど、
ドライバー１つで力づくで開けることができました！
よかったぁ〜
えまってこれ壊れてね？
ちょっと壊れてね？これ
え、まってまって片方しか入んなくなっちゃったよ！
。・゜・(ノД`)・゜・。
ありがとうございました
Thank you for watching!